hey 42 here there are an estimated 7
billion smart devices in the world today
such devices are often referred to as
IOT devices short for Internet of Things
and these can be anything from a smart
speaker smart TV or a smart fridge
basically any appliance inside your home
in your garden or on your driveway that
is connected to the public Internet and
isn't a computer or phone is an IOT
device a Swedish research firm estimates
that by 2020 263 million American homes
will be classified as smart meaning
almost everything in the house perhaps
not always the occupants from the lights
to the locks on the doors will be
automated and connected to the Internet
currently smart devices tell us the
weather give recommendations and can
operate lights curtains or your door
locks what all this is just a tip of the
automation iceberg with ever-increasing
AI capabilities the potential of smart
homes is about to explode
imagine your Smart Watch detects that
you're ill before you even know yourself
you open your front door and the drone
has delivered cold medicine you get a
notification to let you know that's your
workplace has been automatically
notified that you won't be coming in
today due to illness you turn on your
Smart TV to see your favorite film
already loaded up and in the kitchen
you're smart robotic chef is already
preparing a hearty chicken soup
everything will be connected and your
needs will be met before you even know
what they are this will be the future of
the IOT but is this connected future
secure come to think of it our smart
devices and smart homes really secure
right now the truth may shock you the
more smart devices you out to your home
the more potential points of entry for a
hacker you are opening yourself up to
all it takes is one vulnerability or one
weak password for a hacker to enter your
home network and take complete control
of any of your smart devices when
attempting to breach your smart
a hacker will usually try to crack into
your Wi-Fi network this is your homes
single point of failure every smart home
device connects directly to your router
and once a hacker is inside your router
they can do almost anything that you can
do and probably a bit more they can talk
to you through your Google home or to
shopping with your Amazon Alexa unlock
your doors or turn up your smart heating
all the hacker needs to do to gain this
access is park of outside your house and
steal the encrypted password from the
4-way handshake that you're rooted
performs every time a new device tries
to connect to it they will then have a
file with your password inside it on
their laptop the hacker can't actually
see the password because the wpa2 aes
standard means it will be far too
heavily encrypted to simply decrypt on
the spot but they can use a dictionary
attack where their laptop rooms through
every possible combination of password
characters to stumble upon one that
matches the encrypted file and unlocks
it thus giving them your Wi-Fi password
and the ability to connect to it with
any device just as you do all without
you knowing with long passwords a
dictionary attack could take years to
complete but well-prepared hackers will
often offload this processing to a
remote server with extreme computational
power potentially reducing the time to
crack your password to just minutes this
can all be done in less than 15 minutes
without the hack of even leaving their
car the only way to protect yourself
against this hack is by using a long and
highly complex password slowing down the
hacker
exponentially you should use at least 10
or per hand lowercase characters and
include special symbols and numbers
simply adding one extra character to
your existing password could be the
difference between the hacker needing 10
minutes to crack your password to 1 year
because maths so you secured your home
Wi-Fi network
but you're not out of the woods yet far
from it providing that your model of
Rooter doesn't have a unique
vulnerability in its operating system
which I'm afraid is somewhat likely any
one of the smart devices in your home
could have its own vulnerability and
there's not a lot you can do about it a
vulnerability or exploit is a bug or
hole in a piece of software running on a
device that the manufacturer probably
isn't aware of or simply doesn't give a
crap about a hacker can use this
vulnerability to hack into your smart
devices and abuse them without needing
to go to the trouble of hacking into
your home Wi-Fi network at all and they
don't need to be sat in a car outside
your house and these kinds of hacks can
be performed from the other side of the
planet smart devices are all the rage
today and everyone wants to be able to
make coffee from the bath or ask their
fridge to buy more avocados it's a
rapidly growing industry the oakley
downside of this is that thousands of
cheaper mostly chinese design smart home
devices are flooding the market and
vastly undercutting the more premium
competition for example why buy a 300
pound nest security camera when you can
get one of her fifty quid on amazon with
most of the same features I'll tell you
why security to get products to market
quicker and cheaper less well-known
brands sometimes skip possibly the most
important step of developing a new smart
home product penetration testing pen
testing is when a company pays for their
own software to be attacked by white
hack or ethical hackers this process
alerts the company to any
vulnerabilities or bugs so that they can
be patched up before release also most
of the time such companies simply take
an open source or off-the-shelf
operating system from the internet which
are usually riddled with bugs and then
modify it to run on their own device
which usually introduces even more books
then consumers purchase it for a bargain
price and are surprised when they find
out that a hacker has been watching them
sit
sofa eating cheese puffs for the past
six months whereas premium brands
literally spend millions on developing
their own proprietary software to ensure
that hackers cannot easily gain
knowledge of how it works and thus
develop exploits for it now to be clear
no brands not even Google can offer 100%
security in their software but by
spending more on a well-known brand that
you trust you are greatly decreasing the
chance of your smart home devices being
hacked unless of course your nest
password is one two three four five in
which case you deserve to be hacked
because these devices usually sell in
very large quantities and they all use
the exact same software all it takes is
for one hacker to find one vulnerability
on the software of one device and they
have the means to hack into their homes
of millions of people
unbelievably many developers also ship
their products of the same default admin
password that hundreds of thousands of
the same product use all around the
world such as admin one two three and
most consumers never changed these
passwords in 2017 it was reported that a
new botnet called Persie I was
programmed to specifically target IOT
devices in particular cheap IP based
home security cameras over a hundred and
twenty-two thousand Internet connected
security cameras were infected by the
Persei malware
mostly in China and the US because like
I mentioned earlier the manufacturers of
these cheaper cameras tend to skimp on
security it wasn't exactly difficult for
hackers to find a security hole for
their malware they simply exploited an
open port to perform an injection
command that forced the camera to
connect to a URL that downloaded a file
which automatically ran itself on the
cameras hardware thus installing the
malware after which it deleted itself
and ran in the cameras ephemeral memory
so that it couldn't be detected very
the owner of the camera would have no
idea that this ever happened and they
could continue using it to remotely
watch their dogs lick their balls as per
normal but what did the malware do well
it could have been used for the hacker
to spy on the family in question but it
usually wasn't pursue I had bigger fish
to fry all of the hacked IOT devices
created a global botnet a single unified
network or supercomputer that could
launch attacks on large corporations or
even government targets together all
these Hach IOT devices could launch a
devastating DDoS attack or distributed
denial of service this is when thousands
of computers repeatedly found a website
servers to overload it and essentially
take it off the internet the more
devices on the botnet the more powerful
the DDoS attack would be and before per
se right in 2014 there was another
botnet that consisted of over 100,000
devices worldwide 25% of them were not
computers on mobiles but common
household appliances security
researchers found that this particular
Malwa on many smart televisions
multimedia centers and even smart
fridges this particular botnet was used
to send almost 1 million spam emails so
yes refrigerators were sending viagra
ads to random people's inboxes but smart
devices could impact your life and
another way that doesn't involve any
hacking at all
IOT devices could soon control your life
or enable others to take control of you
a few AI companies are already working
with the police to build systems into
Internet connected cars that would allow
the police to monitor your speed on the
road in a few years if you speed in your
new car then it could be remotely
detected by police computers and the
speeding infraction could automatically
be added
to your record and a fine sent straight
to your door experts say that when
combined with internet-connected road
infrastructure the police will even be
able to detect when drivers of smart
cars make illegal lane changes and other
prohibited maneuvers
spookily the police may even be able to
put a limit on your speed from afar if
they determine it to be necessary they
would also be able to bring your smart
car to a complete stop if you fail to
pull over when they flush their lives
and there would be very little you could
do about it
but it gets even more 1984 you may have
heard about Orsino's breathalyzer
interlocks that courts can mandate
convicted drunk drivers to put onto
their cars the driver has to blow into
it and if they're over the limit then
the vehicle will refuse to start but
Volvo is taking this idea a whole step
further and soon you won't even have to
be convicted of drunk driving before
your car takes the moral high ground for
you Volvo are working on a combination
of in-cabin cameras and algorithms that
monitor steering wheel inputs to
automatically determine if the driver at
the wheel is intoxicated or under the
influence of drugs if the car detects
any signs of driver intoxication or if
you have some sort of medical emergency
and lose concentration then it will
automatically slow down the vehicle and
someone from Volvo will call your car
immediately and ask if everything is
okay if you say yes and continue to
drive erratically the car will
automatically pull over in the next
available lay-by at the side of the road
Volvo may choose to call the police this
technology will be in Volvo cars in
early 2020 but it might not be your
smart car that alerts the police to your
drunk driving researchers have found a
way for smartwatches using existing
technology to algorithmically determine
if you are drunk and if you are driving
by utilizing metrics such as your heart
rate and movement speed but what if that
very same Smart Watch
was hacked Yun Wang a computer science
professor at Binghamton University in
New York ran a series of 5,000 tasks on
different wearable smart devices his
team was able to develop an algorithm
that could record the accelerometer and
gyroscope data from hacked devices and
easily determine what's the wearer's
bank penis if they had recently punched
it into an ATM the clever software could
also work out any passwords the wearer
typed into a keyboard based purely on
data from the various onboard sensors
it's similar to how a computer algorithm
could work out a car's final destination
based purely on its starting location
the turns it took and his travel speed
theoretically your SmartWatch could be
remotely infected with a Trojan virus
that could secretly perform all this
algorithmic processing on the device
itself then silently report back to the
hacker with your bank PIN and online
passwords to top it off if a hacker
gained control of your SmartWatch they
could easily monitor your heart rate to
see when you are lying which may not
seem like a huge security concern but a
particularly smart hacker could exploit
a vulnerability with certain brands to
do this on the fly and essentially gain
a superpower where they could tell if
anyone they taught you in real life was
lying or not if they happen to be
wearing that certain brands of
SmartWatch one particular brand of
Chinese SmartWatch aimed at children
were recently found to be easier to hack
Danah toaster me safes were sold in
their thousands on Amazon on eBay they
enabled parents to track their
children's precise movements and
location and call them on demand but it
turns out that these safety watches were
making children less safe than ever
before by using a phenomenally simple
hack that involved changing one digit in
a URL anyone was able to pull up the
location of any child wearing and me
safe and even press a button to call it
security research has found that the
Chinese manufacturer didn't even bother
with security of any kind
there was no encryption and no passwords
the negative connotations of anyone
being able to track your child are so
obvious that security firms were
recommending parents who simply discard
these watches right away to protect
their children as the proliferation of
smart devices increases with phenomenal
haste each year there is going to be a
greater emphasis on security mostly
driven by the bigger brands in the
industry but there will always be
companies that produce cheaper versions
of popular devices that only care about
profits are not consumer safety and
privacy and of every smart device you
add to your life the greater becomes the
risk of your whole personal ecosystem
being hacked but you could reduce that
risk and stay safe with Nord VPN the
only VPN to get a perfect score on PC
Mac Nord VPN have kindly sponsored
today's video they have thousands of
superfast servers in over 60 countries
Nord VPN uses military-grade encryption
and has absolutely no data locking it
works on any device Android iOS Windows
Mac Linux you name it you can even run
odd VPN directly on your router so that
all your home smart devices will be
automatically protected I travel a lot
and I often do sensitive work on my
laptop banking messaging private
documents etc in coffee shops hotel
rooms and public spaces but I always use
non VPN in these instances because it's
so easy for hackers to intercept your
packets over public Wi-Fi and see
everything you're doing online Nord VPN
double encrypt your data so you can use
any Wi-Fi connection 4G or 5g and know
you're completely protected and your
data is secure click my unique link in
the video description to get 70% off a
free year plug and enter the code 40 at
checkout for an extra month completely
free thanks for watching subscribe for a
new video every week and a big THANK YOU
to the sponsor node VP
and don't forget to check them out by
using a link below